je t'ai pas
solana
saignant de villepin mon impression
par déjà sans grand chalon je pense que
ça me démange
il ya plusieurs des exposants de divers
domaines
domaine de l'agriculture
et puis beaucoup de saveur moi ce qui
m'a surtout marqué quand je suis arrivé
c'est vraiment ya énormément de sang
d'heure ça pas sûr que ça mousse aux
fruits de la réunion plein de choses si
on reste dedans des réunionnais si fiers
de leur ville
si fiers de mettre en avant
mais locaux et des produits du terroir
seulement tout simplement le voile
d'ambassadrice de la réunion
présenté il parlait d'elle est aussi
allé à la rencontre pas de nos talents
réunionnais qui se sont déplacés jusqu'à
sur métropole vous met en et en
atteignant comme nous dit pour une
grosse invitation
je dirais varie bonnet à la réunion il
est chaud toute l'année il fait beau
couple année on a blank shot à découvrir
que ça fasse que ça soit parvenu au
paysage par notre vivre ensemble notre
richesse culturelle et déjà la
pensionnaire de ce sera long 7
l'occasion de voir justement tout
là et que l'on chérit tant la menoua et
met en avant
[Musique]